what's the solution what's the solution
so is the solution letting bad ideas go
so far out that it gets so exposed that
finally you know JFK Democrats and
Republicans conservatives say listen man
dude I got a lot more common with you
than I do with these other I don't know
what the hell is going on over here do
we let it to get that bad is that what
we have no other choice to is the other
option which you got Adam kinzinger you
know uh uh comes out a couple days ago
it says Misty eyed Adam kinzinger says
conservatives will be the first to die
in a civil war so is the second option
you know we go through some like this
where in a response to a comment about
Republican on Twitter Adam Kensington
openly fantasize about a country being
driven towards Civil War and suggested
that anti-war conservatives will be the
first to die kenzinger made the comments
in response to a user who went on a mile
rant about Republicans not supporting
the war effort in Ukraine referring to
them as fascists and labeling them as
their gqp party True Rewards have never
been spoken kinzinger replied spoiled
people who have never seen War like to
play dress up if there is a civil war
they will be the first to pass away
because Walgreens will run out of heart
medicine right so he makes comments like
this so option number one let bad ideas
uh play out and everyone's gonna unite
number two Civil War number three you
know uh unified bring everybody together
on one side you know together to sit
down and talk number four do what musk
and some others are talking about hey
just vote Republican what is the
solution number three bringing everybody
together that's I think we're way past
the option I don't think that's gonna
happen I don't think there's anybody out
there that that can happen I I don't I I
think we're living number one letting
these ideas get so rotten that the bill
Mars or the world go wait a minute I'm
not on the left anymore because that's
idiocy
um and Joe Rogan who was who was very
far left and and in his understanding
that the right actually isn't what the
left would have you believe it is
um
the Civil War thing for me is and one
thing I've learned uh growing up as a
military brat and being around the
military is the last people in the world
who want conflict are the ones who have
seen it
they understand the price and and you
know having been in and seen an active
war zone and and seeing what it looks
like and what it does you know I would
certainly never want to but I'm also on
not even remotely uncomfortable at the
thought of standing up to defend and
fight for my country physically if
that's what it meant
um
I don't again I said I think both sides
are so far apart and see each other as
such bad people that there is no
Bridging the Gap my question has been
for 10 years
um
former military and Military and law
enforcement I and I you know having kind
of spread myself into those circles and
and tried to have those people as much
as I can in my life I asked the same
question
Mike I'm gonna look to you
if the rubber meets the road I'm
starting to see videos of ATF agents and
FBI agents knocking on the doors of
law-abiding Americans asking them if
they're they possess a certain item that
they bought legally and if they did so
would they turn it over I never thought
that was even remotely something that
would ever happen
and my question is to law enforcement
what are you going to do are you going
to enforce the law you know to be or or
an order that you know to be
unconstitutional because the oath you
took was foreign and domestic right
enemies foreign and domestic
what does a domestic enemy look like
because my argument is it looks sort of
like what we're seeing it looks sort of
like people who are
locking the country down for two years
over what we now know was enormous power
play and was a bunch of [ __ ] and we
were being lied to about the vaccine and
all the other things around that and we
were finding out that all the the
quote-unquote deaths were those with
comorbidities and 90 of these people
were elderly and overweight and had all
the things that people die from the flu
from
all of the like that's the thing is I
get the feeling that the Liberals that I
see and the Democrats that I see truly
hate well I mean the president came out
and talked about
fighting
Mega Americans right if you're going to
fight the government we have nuclear
weapons in f-16s I mean open I've never
heard
to think that a president would even
utter that much less say at a press
conference is mind-boggling to me I I
think there's a combination of all of
those things like I said I think we're
living number one I think we're letting
bad ideas play out yeah and I think we
feel like we have to I don't I think we
feel like we're powerful and I'll say
this Jim Jordan
I'm so I'm a fan I'm so tired of seeing
him complain on Twitter
and I've I've written to him a couple
times saying just shut up you got
elected to fix it stop complaining on
Twitter and do something about it
because you sound like a voter you sound
like me I'm complaining to you
and you're who you I you if you can't do
anything then resign and put somebody in
the office that has the guts to do
something because I'm tired of hearing
them Rand Paul and all of them again
same thing committee after committee
after committee no one ever actually
does anything what can they do I I don't
know
but I know I'm powerless unless I take
up arms against and then a sitting
government which I'm not going to do
yeah what I can't do anything I have
don't we elect these people to steer the
country and by steer I mean hold on to
the wheel and move us in a Direction
what if if we know people are breaking
the law which we know we know the the
the last Democratic party in the last
Administration that was Democrat
weaponized the doj
I mean that much we know Comey and all
the things that went with that I mean we
watched Comey James Comey stand up in
front of the mic and talk about
Clinton's crimes and say that word not
enough for prosecute
and now we we I mean I follow along some
of the Giuliani stuff the stuff that's
been done to him since
Trump has been in my in May facets that
I've read unconstitutional and against
the law
again law enforcement agents knocking on
Americans doors asking
to have items that were legally
purchased to turn that in and then being
told and the person saying do you have a
warrant no I don't have a warrant but
you don't need to be a jerk about it you
know you can just give me the item and
we'll go away and he's like no I'm not
doing that and he's like well we'll
probably see you again down the road
like they're threatening us
that's the gov that's that's Russia
that's Eastern Europe that's fascism at
its core and it's happening live and and
the the internet's allowing us to see it
that's the even worse part and we're
still doing nothing about it
Tom how do you process it what do you
think is going to happen with this is it
playing it out is it playing it out is
it let it play out is it number two you
know uh uh a civil war is going to
happen a republican is going to get
elected is it what do you think is going
to happen unifying forces in the history
of America have always been very violent
um and it's very sad 911 was a unifying
force a tremendous unifying force we
didn't care what color you were
we didn't care anything about it we were
just tall
we were hurting we were pro-us we were
pro-us and we saw us getting together
those uh was it nine days later and the
NFL was this healing moment on Sunday
and we talked about praying together we
talked about unifying we talked about
helping we talk about reaching out
unifying forces are usually very very
violent and the the problem with the
political structure is it's it's a power
and economic structure it's not just a
power structure and the the where words
have to be weaponized you have to create
such hatred to move these voting blocks
at least that's what they think and you
take billions and billions of dollars
from people that want hundreds and
hundreds of favors later
um that's the way this works
um
and I I I think you need to get there's
got to be a unifying force and I don't
wish it on this country I don't wish it
on any person but there's got to be a
unifying force that comes together of it
and it's usually it's usually when
people realize we don't have it so bad
and something really horrible has just
gone down and my goodness we do have it
better than we thought we did so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]